hormonal birth control is bad I don't
think women should be on birth control
why doctors will tell you oh we can help
your acne will regulate your Cycles but
they don't actually regulate your Cycles
being on the pill all it does is like
chemically disrupt your hormones and
stop like needed hormones for your body
not just for your reproductive cycle but
for your full mental well-being as a
woman it changes who you are attracted
to because your hormones are all screwed
up and we are naturally so attracted to
people based on our biology and when
that is chemically altered that takes a
toll how does a pill cause you to like
gain so much weight change so much about
your body your periods just stop your
periods are not supposed to just stop
the copper IUD it actually makes the
uterus an inhospitable environment for
any kind of sperm and any kind of
pregnancy so when you have a copper IUD
your entire body is inflamed constantly
because you have a piece of metal in you
usually your iron gets depleted when you
have one because you are losing so much
blood more than you need to be a lot of
women have a lot of problems getting
pregnant after being on birth control
for a long time